[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais vous raconter une petite
histoire cet après-midi une petite
histoire qui commence par il était une
fois il était une fois un pays d'environ
8 millions d'habitants 3h30 c'est le
temps qu'il faut pour passer d'un côté à
l'autre de ce beau petit pays au cœur de
l'Europe et pourtant nous les habitants
de ce petit pays on vit dans une
relative indifférence les uns par
rapport aux autres étonnamment pourquoi
ça c'est ce que nous allons un petit peu
voir aujourd'hui on nous a souvent dit
que en fait la Suisse fonctionnait bien
parce que justement on ne se comprend
pas vraiment et c'est ça que nous allons
voir ensemble cet après-midi
on peut vraiment dire que voilà quelque
chose qui nous unit finalement c'est ça
qu'on cherche à savoir est-ce que nous
avons vraiment des choses qui nous
réunissent ou est-ce que finalement les
langues nous séparent alors ce qu'on
voit là sur cette image c'est quand même
ce Graben ce Graben vous décrivez en
allemand une ruche qui grab un fossé et
nous en français nous y voyons une
barrière on l'appelle pour les
italophones une polenta grave donc c'est
aussi possible de voir les choses comme
ça mais c'est vrai que nous aimons voir
les choses qui nous réunissent ce que je
veux vous montrer là c'est que malgré
tout et malgré ce qu'on a entendu
précédemment on n'a pas encore trouvé un
mot équivalent en anglais pour définir
ce qui nous sépare un peu mais quand
même ce qui nous tient ensemble
[Musique]
parlons-nous Suisse wish sprichmann
c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup de de
cohésion de diversité linguistique
les langues sont une de nos richesses
indécimens de notre pays nous en faisons
finalement très peu usage nous avons
quatre langues dont trois sont des
langues européennes majeures l'allemand
le français l'italien bien sûr ça c'est
dans les textes c'est officiel c'est ce
qu'on trouve dans les lois mais aucune
loi ne va vous parler de ces dialectes
des dialectes
on oublie aussi que cette Suisse est
constituée de toutes ces langues de
toute cette richesse avec en tête
l'anglais et le Portugais je ne sais pas
si vous le saviez savez-vous d'ailleurs
que à Sierre on dit que la ville de
Sierre site
aussi une forme de bilinguisme c'est une
forme de vivre ensemble c'est vrai que
ce ciment n'est pas une chose donnée
c'est vrai que c'est censé nous enrichir
mais on voit aussi qu'il y a des
difficultés à être ensemble
est-ce que l'on parle Suisse j'ai envie
de vous dire oui on parle Suisse c'est
existe-t-il helvétisme
oui on a des mots comme pepperoni gutsly
à Berlin et que vous essayez de demander
un gutsly et bien je pense que vous
allez avoir de la peine à être servi en
parlant de Berlin à une berline non
c'est pas la même chose en français nous
parlons d'une boule de Berlin nulle part
ailleurs on parle de boules de Berlin ou
d'une Brussel ou d'une pive donc on voit
que nous avons des choses qui sont
véritablement
identitaires qui sont très fortes ici
dans ce pays mais qu'on sous-estime
c'est ce qu'il y a c'est quelque chose
de très intéressant en Suisse c'est que
finalement les gens de l'extérieur vous
avez certainement tous fait l'expérience
il pense tous que les Suisses sont
plurilingues il y a CLA anne-mère
donc nous sommes relativement tous
isolés c'est vrai que je ne vous ai pas
parlé d'un exemple on a parlé du Graben
tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai que ce
grabone on a tendance à le situer entre
la Suisse romande et la Suisse
alémanique mais ce n'est pas seulement
là qu'il existe si on regarde si je me
déplace à Genève qui est dans une zone
très française et bien là aussi il y a
une forme de Graham entre les Français
d'un côté et les Genevois qui ne se
sentent pas vraiment français vous avez
les mêmes choses qui s'appliquent pour
les Valaisans pour la Suisse centrale on
voit que ces choses sont ne sont pas
aussi claires et définis et que parfois
ça nous arrange d'envisager un graven
entre suisse allemand et Suisse à
l’émanique et parfois ça nous arrange de
nous voir comme étant à unique comme
étant ensemble
il y a un village d'Astérix c'est cette
ville de Bienne parce que elle est
plurilingue dans le sens que on la
décrit souvent comme une petite Suisse
une petite Suisse linguistique ou toutes
les langues peuvent cohabiter et
effectivement où les langues ont un rôle
de d'unifiant de démocratie
effectivement le rôle des langues n'est
pas seulement celui d'être
utile de pouvoir communiquer il y a
cloud assister
on peut faire des fautes il n'y a pas de
problème si moi je vous parle en
français ou j'amène aussi un bout de ma
culture ma culture n'est pas française
les langues ici sont phénomènes
d'inclusion ça veut dire que nous
prenons les gens ensemble nous les
mettons ensemble nous aussi les langues
de la migration pour finalement avoir un
objectif commun la communication être
ensemble sous amen libre
islandais
comme je vous ai raconté cette histoire
à Neya
normal
ça veut dire que je devrais vous dire
que finalement tout va bien dans le
meilleur des mondes comme à Bienne c'est
ça l'histoire d'un conte comme j'ai
commencé mon mon petit récit il y a
quelques minutes et finalement tout
n'est pas exactement comme ça et à
l'image et pour paraphraser Stéphane
Hessel qui en 2010 avait commis un petit
un petit opuscule qui s'appelait
indignez-vous et bien j'ai envie de vous
dire un
purtis nordneautique
j'ai vraiment envie de vous encourager
bien sûr on n'est pas dans l'opposition
avec l'anglais c'est vraiment dans
l'idée qu'on est on apporte plus de nous
en étant dans nos langues et
effectivement cet après-midi nous avons
entendu beaucoup de gens parler
l'anglais utiliser l'anglais il y a
Clara Ted comme house America
film
c'est le message aussi de la Fondation
c'est vraiment l'idée que nous pouvons
la fond forum du bilinguisme c'est
l'idée que nous pouvons vivre mieux
ensemble qui évidemment ça nécessite
l'engagement de tous et de toutes vous
ici bien sûr mais d'être des
multiplicateurs de ça des rames
contrôleur que je prône
oh stop in English please
je pense que ça pour moi c'est la limite
de la communication avec l'anglais et je
pense qu'on peut adhérer à ça à trouver
un chemin pour que nous ayons un minimum
sur lequel nous puissions échanger
ensemble on peut y travailler il faut
produire des outils concrets c'est ce à
quoi nous travaillons avec la Fondation
on a un projet qui s'appelle retenez le
nom il lui reviendra certainement qui
s'appelle
chlingua à Sota
oui parce que il y a des jolies
histoires qui se passent et en ce moment
il y a un Erasmus culturel qui réunit
un théâtre zurichois qui se produit en
ce moment à Lausanne c'est de plus en
plus fréquent qu'on essaie de mettre
ensemble nos cultures mais ce qui est
surtout intéressant c'est que lorsqu'on
regarde ces exemples et bien souvent on
trouve des Allemands des français et non
pas des Suisses à la tête de ces de ces
de ces organisations et je trouve que
nous pourrions tirer un meilleur parti
nous qui sommes sur ce territoire
européen nous pourrions tirer un
meilleur parti des langues qui nous
enrichissent et pouvoir être fiers de
cette mise en commun voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire cet après-midi je vous
remercie de votre écoute
[Applaudissements]